if you had to judge your version of Shaq
and Magic vers La Shaq what do you think
the pros and cons for both of them were
what was better The Shaq in Orlando was
a runner that's because I used to get
the ball Penny was a pass first guy you
know so when you get the ball do your
thing La Shack was more dominant more
focused had better help around me and
the general didn't Panic the general
doesn't panic which is the coach and the
players won't Panic Phil was like nope
I'm not calling the timeout you guys
figured out and he treated us like men
and I had another dog next to I'm not
going to see her act like I did it by
myself I had a dog next to me who wanted
who had the same mentality that that I
had we were supposed to win and we did
[Music]
win